PETER SZOLOVITS: Fortunately,
I have a guest today, Dr. Adam
Wright, who will be doing
an interview-style session
and will answer
questions for you.
This is Adam's bread
and butter, exactly how
to translate this kind of
technology into the clinic.
He's currently in the partner
system at the Brigham, I guess.
But he's about to become a
traitor and leave us in Boston
and occupy a position at
Vanderbilt University,
for which we wish him luck.
But I'm glad that we caught him
before he leaves this summer.
OK, so quite frankly, I
wish that I could tell you
a much happier
story than the one
that you're going to hear from
me during the prepared part
of my talk.
And maybe Adam will cheer us
up and make us more optimistic,
based on his experience.
So you may have
noticed that AI is hot.
So HIMSS, for example, is the
Health Information Management
Systems Society.
It's a big-- they
hold annual meetings
and consist of a lot of
vendors and a lot of academics.
And it's one of these huge
trade show kinds of things,
with balloons hanging over
booths and big open spaces.
So for example,
they're now talking
about a AI-powered health care.
On the other hand, it's
important to remember
this graph.
So this is the sort of
technology adoption graph.
And it's called the hype cycle.
And what you see
here is that R&D--
that's us-- produces some
wonderful, interesting idea.
And then all of a sudden,
people get excited about it.
So who are the people that
get most excited about it?
It's the people who
think they're going
to make a fortune from it.
And these are the so-called
vulture capitalists--
venture capitalists.
And so the venture
capitalists come in
and they encourage
people like us to go out
and found companies-- or if
not us, then our students to go
found companies.
And figure out how to
turn this nascent idea
into some important
moneymaking enterprise.
Now the secret of
venture capital
is that they know that about 90%
of the companies that they fund
are going to tank.
They're going to do very badly.
And so as a result, what they
hope for and what they expect--
and what the good
ones actually get--
is that one in 10 that
becomes successful
makes so much money
that it makes up
for all of the investment that
they poured into the nine out
of 10 that do badly.
So I actually
remember in the 1990s,
I was helping a
group pitch a company
to Kleiner Perkins, which
is the big venture--
one of the big venture capital
funds in Silicon Valley.
And we walked into
their boardroom
and they had a copy of
the San Jose Mercury News,
which is the local newspaper for
Silicon Valley, on their table.
And they were just
beaming, because there
was an article that said
that in the past year,
the two best and the two worst
investments in Silicon Valley
had been by their company.
But that's pretty good, right?
If you get two winners
and two really bad losers,
you're making tons
and tons of money.
So they were in a good
mood and they funded us.
We didn't make them any money.
So what you see on this
curve is that there
is a kind of set of
rising expectations that
comes from the development
of these technologies.
And you have some
early adopters.
And then you have the
newspapers writing
about how this is the
revolution and everything will
be different from here on out.
Then you have some
additional activity
beyond the early adopters.
And then people start
looking at this and going,
well, it really isn't as good
as it's cracked up to be.
Then you have the
steep decline where
there's some consolidation
and some failures.
And people have to go
back to venture capital
to try to get more
money in order
to keep their companies going.
And then there's
a kind of trough,
where people go, oh well, this
was another of these failed
technological innovations.
Then gradually, you start
reaching what this author calls
the slope of enlightenment,
where people realize that,
OK, it's not really as bad as
we thought it was when it didn't
meet our lofty expectations.
And then gradually,
if it's successful,
then you get multiple
generations of the product
and it does achieve adoption.
The adoption almost
never reaches the peak
that it was expected to reach at
the time of the top of the hype
cycle.
But it becomes useful.
It becomes profitable.
It becomes productive.
Now I've been around long enough
to see a number of these cycles
go by.
So in the 1980s, for example,
at a time that was now jokingly
referred to as AI summer--
where people were building
expert systems and these expert
systems were going to just
revolutionize everything--
I remember going to a conference
where the Campbell Soup
Company had built an
expert system that
was based on the expertise
of some old timers who
were retiring.
And what this expert
system did is it told you
how to clean the vats of soup--
y know, these giant
million-gallon things where
they make soup--
when you're switching from
making one kind of soup
to another.
So you know, if you're
making beef consomme
and you switch to
making beef barley soup,
you don't need to
clean the vat at all.
Whereas if you're switching
from something like clam chowder
to a consomme, then you need
to clean it really well.
So this was exactly the kind
of thing that they were doing.
And there were
literally thousands
of these applications
being built.
At the top of the
hype cycle, all kinds
of companies, like Campbell's
Soup and the airlines
and everybody was investing
huge amounts of money into this.
And then there was a kind
of failure of expectations.
These didn't turn out to be
as good as people thought
they were going to be,
or as valuable as people
thought they were going to be.
And then all of a
sudden came AI winter.
So AI winter followed AI summer.
There was no AI fall,
except in a different sense
of the word fall.
And all of a sudden,
funding dried up
and the whole thing
was declared a failure.
But in fact today, if you go
out there and you look at--
Microsoft Excel has an expert
system-based help system
bundled inside it.
And there are tons
of such applications.
It's just that now
they're no longer
considered cutting-edge
applications
of artificial intelligence.
They're simply considered
routine practice.
So they've become
incorporated, without the hype,
into all kinds of
existing products.
And they're serving
a very useful role.
But they didn't make
those venture capital
firms the tons of money
that they had hoped to make.
There was a similar
boom and bust
cycle in the 2000s around the
creation of the worldwide web
and e-commerce.
OK, so e-commerce.
Again, there was this
unbelievably inflated set
of expectations.
Then around the year 2000,
there was a big crash,
where all of a sudden
people realized
that the value in
these applications
was not as high as what
they expected it to be.
Nevertheless, you know
Amazon is doing just fine.
And there are plenty of
online e-commerce sites
that are in perfectly good
operating order today.
But it's no longer the same
hype about this technology.
It's just become an
accepted part of the way
that you do business
in almost everything.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you
speak of expert systems,
does that mean
rule-based systems?
PETER SZOLOVITS: They were
either rule-based or pattern
matching systems.
There were two basic kinds.
I think a week from today,
I'm going to talk about some
of that and how it relates
to modern machine learning.
So we'll see some examples.
OK, well, a cautionary tale
is IBM's Watson Health.
So I assume most of
you remember when
Watson hit the big time by
beating the Jeopardy champions.
This was back in the
early 2010s or something.
I don't remember
exactly which year.
And they had, in fact, built
a really impressive set
of technologies that
went out and read
all kinds of online
sources and distilled them
into a kind of representation
that they could very
quickly look up things when they
were challenged with a Jeopardy
question.
And then it had a
sophisticated set
of algorithms that would
try to find the best
answer for some question.
And they even had all kinds of
bizarre special-purpose things.
I remember there was a
probabilistic model that
figured out where
the Daily Double
squares were most likely to
be on the Jeopardy board.
And then they did a utility
theoretic calculation
to figure out if they
did hit the Daily Double,
what was the optimum
amount of money to bet,
based on the
machine's performance,
in order to optimize.
They decided that
humans typically
don't bet enough when they have
a chance on the Daily Double.
So there was a lot of
very special-purpose stuff
done for this.
So this was a huge
publicity bonanza.
And IBM decided that next they
were going to tackle medicine.
So they were going to
take this technology
and apply it to medicine.
They were going to read
all of the medical journals
and all of the electronic
medical records
that they could
get their hands on.
And somehow this
technology would again
distill the right
information, so that they
could answer questions
like a Jeopardy question,
except not stated in
its funny backward way.
Where you might say,
OK, for this patient,
what is the optimum therapy?
And it would go out and
use the same technology
to figure that out.
Now that was a perfectly
reasonable thing to try.
The problem they ran
into was this hype cycle,
that the people who
made this publicly-known
were their marketing people
and not their technical people.
And the marketing people
overpromised like crazy.
They said surely
this is just going
to solve all these problems.
And we won't need anymore
research in this area,
because man, we got it.
I'm overstating it, even from
the marketing point of view.
And so Watson for Oncology used
this cloud-based supercomputer
to digest massive
amounts of data.
That data included all
kinds of different things.
So I'm going to go into
a little bit of detail
about what some of
their problems were.
This is from an article
in this journal, Statnews,
which did an investigative piece
on what happened with Watson.
So you know, they
say what I just said.
Breathlessly promoting
its signature brand,
IBM sought to capture
the world's imagination
and quickly zeroed in on
a high-profile target,
which was cancer.
So this was going to solve
the problem of some patient
shows up, is
diagnosed with cancer,
and you want to know how
to treat this person.
So this would use
all of the literature
and all of everything
that it had
gathered from
previous treatments
of previous patients.
And it would give you
the optimal solution.
Now it has not been a success.
There are a few dozen hospitals
that have adopted the system.
Very few of them in the United
States, more of them abroad.
And the foreigners
complain that its advice
is biased toward
American patients
and American approaches.
To me, the biggest problem
is that they haven't actually
published anything
that validates,
in a scientific sense,
that this is a good idea.
That it's getting
the right answers.
My guess is the
reason for this is
because it's not getting
the right answers,
a lot of the time.
But that doesn't prevent
marketing from selling it.
The other problem is that they
made a deal with Memorial Sloan
Kettering-- which is one of
the leading cancer hospitals
in the country--
to say, we're going to work with
you guys and your oncologists
in order to figure out what
really is the right answer.
So I think they tried to do
what their marketing says
that they're doing,
which is to really derive
the right answer from
reading all of the literature
and looking at past cases.
But I don't think that
worked well enough.
And so what they wound
up doing is turning
to real oncologists,
saying, what would you
do under these circumstances?
And so what they
wound up building
is something like a
rule-based system that says,
if you see the
following symptoms
and you have the
following genetic defects,
then this is the
right treatment.
So the promise
that this was going
to be a machine learning system
that revolutionized cancer
care by finding the
optimal treatment really
is not what they provided.
And as the article
says, the system
doesn't really
create new knowledge.
So it's AI only in the
sense of providing a search
engine that, when it
makes a recommendation,
can point you to articles that
are a reasonable reflection
of what it's recommending.
Well, I'm going to stop
going through this litany.
But you'll see it in the
slides, which we'll post.
They had a big contract
with M.D. Anderson,
which is another leading cancer
center in the United States.
M.D. Anderson spent about
$60 million on this contract,
implementing it.
And they pulled the plug on it,
because they decided that it
just wasn't doing the job.
Now by contrast, there was a
much more successful attempt
years ago, which was less driven
by marketing and more driven
by medical need.
And the idea here was CPOE,
stands for Computerized
Physician Order Entry.
The idea behind
CPOE was that if you
want to affect the
behavior of clinicians
in ordering tests or drugs or
procedures, what you want to do
is to make sure that they are
interacting with the computer.
So that when they
order, for example,
some insanely expensive drug,
the system can come back
and say, hey, do you
realize that there's
a drug that costs 1/100
as much, which according
to the clinical trials
that we have on record
is just as effective as the
one that you've ordered?
And so for example, here at
the Beth Israel many years ago,
they implemented a
system like that.
And in the first
year, they showed
that they saved something like
$16 million in the pharmacy,
just by ordering cheaper
variants of drugs that
could have been very expensive.
And they also found
that the doctors who
were doing the ordering were
perfectly satisfied with that,
because they just didn't know
how expensive these drugs were.
That's not one of the things
that they pay attention to.
So there are many
applications like that
that are driven by this.
And again, here are
some statistics.
You can reduce
error rates by half.
You can reduce severe
medication errors by 88%.
You can have a 70% reduction in
antibiotic-related adverse drug
events.
You can reduce length of stay,
which is another big goal
that people go after.
And at least if
you're an optimist,
you can believe
these extrapolations
that say, well, we could
prevent 3 million adverse drug
events at big city hospitals
in the United States
if everybody used
systems like this.
So the benefits
are that it prompts
with warnings against possible
drug interactions, allergies,
or overdoses.
It can be kept up to date by
some sort of mechanism where
people read the
literature and keep
updating the databases
this is driven from.
And it can do mechanical
things like eliminate confusion
about drug names
that sound similar.
Stuff like that.
So the Leapfrog Group, which
does a lot of meta analyses
and studies of what's
effective, really
is behind this and
pushing it very strongly.
Potential future
benefits, of course,
are that if the kinds of
machine learning techniques
that we talk about
become widely used,
then these systems can be
updated automatically rather
than by manual review.
And you can gain the advantages
of immediate feedback
as new information
becomes available.
Now the adoption of CPOE was
recommended by the National
Academy of Medicine.
They wanted every hospital
to use this by 1999.
And of course, it
hasn't happened.
So I couldn't find current
data, but 2014 data
shows that CPOE, for example,
for medication orders,
is only being used in
about 25% of the hospitals.
And at that time, people were
extrapolating and saying, well,
it's not going to reach 80%
penetration until the year
2029.
So it's a very slow
adoption cycle.
Maybe it's gotten better.
The other problem-- and one of
the reasons for resistance--
is that it puts additional
stresses on people.
So for example, this
is a study of how
pharmacists spend their time.
So clinical time is useful.
That's when they're
consulting with doctors,
helping them figure
out appropriate dosage
for patients.
Or they're talking to
patients, explaining to them
how to take their medications,
what side effects to watch out
for, et cetera.
These distributive tasks--
it's a funny term--
mean the non-clinical part
of what they're doing.
And what you see is
that hospitals that
have adopted CPOE, they wind up
spending a little bit more time
on the distributive tasks
and a little bit less time
on the clinical tasks.
Which is probably not
in the right direction,
in terms of what
pharmacists were hoping
for out of systems like this.
Now people have
studied the diffusion
of new medical technologies.
And I think I'll just
show you the graph.
So this is in England, but this
is the adoption for statins.
So from the time they
were introduced--
statins is the drug that
keeps your cholesterol low.
From the time they
were introduced
until they were being
used, essentially,
at 100% of places was about
five and a half, six years.
So reasonably fast.
If you look at the adoption
of magnetic resonance imaging
technology, it took
five years for it
to have any adoption whatsoever.
And that's because it
was insanely expensive.
So there were all
kinds of limitations.
You know, even in
Massachusetts, you
have to get permission
from some state committee
to buy a new MRI machine.
And if another hospital in
your town already had one,
then they would say, well,
you shouldn't buy one
because you should be able to
use this other hospital's MRI
machine.
Same thing happened with CT.
But as soon as those
limitations were lifted, boom.
It went up and then
continues to go up.
Whereas stents, I
actually don't know why
they were delayed by that long.
But this is for people with
blockages in coronary arteries
or other arteries.
You can put in a
little mesh tube that
just keeps that artery open.
And that adoption
was incredibly quick.
So different things get
adopted at different rates.
Now the last topic I want
to talk about before--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what
happens in those years
where you just have spikes?
What's doing it?
PETER SZOLOVITS: So
according to those authors,
in the case of stents,
there were some champions
of the idea of stenting
who went around
and convinced their
colleagues that this was
the right technology to use.
So there was just an
explosive growth in it.
In the other technologies,
in the MRI case,
money mattered a lot because
they're so expensive.
Stents are relatively cheap.
And in the case
of statins, those
are also relatively cheap.
Or they've become cheap
since they went off patent.
Originally, they were
much more expensive.
But there are still
adoption problems.
So for example, there
was a recommendation--
I think about 15, maybe
even 20 years ago--
that said that anybody
who has had a heart
attack or coronary
artery disease
should be taking beta blockers.
And I don't remember what
the adoption rate is today,
but it's only on
the order of a half.
And so why?
This is a dirt cheap drug.
For reasons not
quite understood,
it reduces the probability
of having a second heart
attack by about 35%.
So it's a really
cheap protective way
of keeping people healthier.
And yet it just hasn't
suffused practice as much
as people think it should have.
All right.
So how do we assure the
quality of these technologies
before we foist
them on the world?
This is tricky.
So John Ioannidis, a
Stanford professor,
has made an extremely
successful career
out of pointing out that most
biomedical research is crap.
It can't be reproduced.
And there are some
famous publications
that show that people have
taken some area of biomedicine,
and they've looked at a bunch
of well-respected published
studies.
And they've gone to
the lab and they've
tried to replicate
those studies.
Half the time or
three-quarters of the time,
they fail to do so.
You go, oh my god,
this is horrible.
It is horrible.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mean like
they failed to do so,
so they won't reproduce
the exact same results?
Or what exactly--
PETER SZOLOVITS:
Worse than that.
So it's not that there
are slight differences.
It's that, for
example, a result that
was shown to be statistically
significant in one study, when
they repeat the
study, is no longer
statistically significant.
That's bad, if you base policy
on that kind of decision.
So Ioannidis has a
suggestion, which
would probably help a lot.
And that is,
basically, make known
to everybody all the
studies that have failed.
So the problem is that if
you give me a big data set
and I start mining
this data set,
I'm going to find tons and tons
of interesting correlations
in this data.
And as soon as I get one
that has a good p value,
my students and I go, fantastic.
Time to publish.
Now consider the
fact that I'm not
the only person in this role.
So you know, David's group
is doing the same thing.
And John Guttag's and
Regina Barzilay's and all
of our colleagues at every
other major university
and hospital in
the United States.
So there may be
hundreds of people
who are mining this data.
And each of us has slightly
different ways of doing it.
We select our cases differently.
We preprocess the
data differently.
We apply different learning
algorithms to them.
But just by random
chance, some of us
are going to find interesting
results, interesting patterns.
And of course, those are
the ones that get published.
Because if you don't find
an interesting result,
you're not going to submit
it to a journal and say,
you know I looked for the
following fact phenomenon
and I was unable to find it.
Because the journal
says, well, that's
not interesting to anybody.
So Ioannidis is recommending
that, basically,
every study that anybody
undertakes should
be registered.
And if you don't get
a significant result,
that should be known.
And this would allow
us to make at least
some reasonable estimate of
whether the significant results
that were gotten are just
the statistical outliers that
happened to reach p equal 0.05
or whatever your threshold is,
or whether it's a real effect
because not that many people
have been trying this.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
why do you think this is?
Is it because of the size
of some core patients?
Or bias in the assay?
Or just purely
randomness in the study?
PETER SZOLOVITS: It
could be any of those.
It could be that your
hospital has some biased data
collection.
And so you find an effect.
My hospital doesn't,
and so I don't find it.
It could be that we just
randomly sub-sampled
a different sample
of the population.
So it's very interesting.
Last year I was
invited to a meeting
by Jeff Drazen, who's the
executive editor of the New
England Journal.
And he's thinking about--
has not decided--
but he's thinking
about a policy for the
New England Journal, which
is like the top medical journal,
that says that he will not
publish any result unless
it's been replicated
on two independent data sets.
So that's interesting.
And that's an attempt to fight
back against this problem.
It's a different solution than
what Ioannidis is recommending.
So this was a study
by Enrico Carrara.
And he's talking about
what it means to replicate.
And again, I'm not going
to go through all this.
But there's the notion
that replication might
mean exact replication, i.e.
You do exactly the same thing on
exactly the same kind of data,
but in a different data set.
And then partial replication,
conceptual replication,
which says, you follow
the same procedures
but in a different environment.
And then quasi replication--
either partial or conceptual.
And these have various
characteristics
that you can look at.
It's an interesting framework.
So this is not a new idea.
The first edition of this
book, Evaluation Methods
in Biomedical Informatics,
was called Evaluation Methods
in Medical Informatics
by the same authors
and was published
a long time ago.
I can't remember.
This one is relatively recent.
And so they do a multi-hundred
page, very detailed evaluation
of exactly how one
should evaluate
clinical systems like this.
And it's very careful
and very cautious,
but it's also very conservative.
So for example, one of the
things that they recommend
is that the people
doing the evaluation
should not be the people
who developed the technique,
because there's innately bias.
You know, I want my
technique to succeed.
And so they say, hand
it off to somebody
else who doesn't have
that same vested interest.
And then you're going to get
a more careful evaluation.
So Steve Pauker and
I wrote a response
to one of their early
papers recommending
this that said, well, that's
so conservative that it
sort of throws the baby
out with the bathwater.
Because if you make it so
difficult to do an evaluation,
you'll never get
anything past it.
So we proposed instead a
kind of staged evaluation
that says, first of all, you
should do regression testing
so that every time you use
these agile development methods,
you should have the set of
cases that your program has
worked on before.
You should
automatically rerun them
and see which ones
you've made better
and which ones
you've made worse.
And that will give
you some insight
into whether what you're
doing is reasonable.
Then you might also
build tools that
look at automating ways of
looking for inconsistencies
in the models that
you're building.
Then you have retrospective
review, judged by clinicians.
So you run a program
that you like
over a whole bunch
of existing data,
like what you're doing with
Mimic or with Market Scan.
And then you do
it prospectively,
but without actually
affecting patients.
So you do it in real time
as the data is coming in,
but you don't tell anybody
what the program results in.
You just ask them to
evaluate in retrospect
to see whether it was right.
And you might say, well,
what's the difference
between collecting
the data in real time
and collecting the
data retrospectively?
Historically, the answer
is there is a difference.
So circumstances differ.
The mechanisms that you have
for collecting the data differ.
So this turns out to
be an important issue.
And then you can run a
prospective controlled trial
where you're interested in
evaluating both the answer
that you get from the
program, and ultimately
the effect on health outcomes.
So if I have a decision
support system,
the ultimate proof
of the pudding
is if I run that
decision support system.
I give advice to
clinicians, the clinicians
change their behavior
sometimes, and the patients
get a better outcome.
Then I'm convinced that
this is really useful.
But you have to
get there slowly,
because you don't want to
give them worse outcomes.
That's unethical and
probably illegal.
And you want to compare
this to the performance
of unaided doctors.
So the Food and
Drug Administration
has been dealing with this
issue for many, many years.
I remember talking to
them in about 1976, when
they were reading about the
very first expert system
programs for diagnosis
and therapy selection.
And they said, well, how
should we regulate these?
And my response at the
time was, God help us.
Keep your hands off.
Because if you regulate
it, then you're
going to slow down progress.
And in any case, none of
these programs are being used.
These programs are
being developed
as experimental programs
in experimental settings.
They're not coming
anywhere close to being
used on real patients.
And so there is not
a regulatory issue.
And about every five years, FDA
has revisited that question.
And they have continued to make
essentially the same decision,
based on the rationale
that, for example, they
don't regulate books.
If I write a textbook
that explains something
about medicine, the
FDA is not going
to see whether it's
correct or not.
And the reason is
because the expectation
is that the textbook is
making recommendations,
so to speak, to clinical
practitioners who are
responsible experts themselves.
So the ultimate responsibility
for how they behave
rests with them and
not with the textbook.
And they said, we're going to
treat these computer programs
as if they were dynamic
textbooks, rather
than colleagues who are acting
independently and giving
advice.
Now as soon as you try
to give that advice, not
to a professional,
but to a patient, then
you are immediately under the
regulatory auspices of FDA.
Because now there is no
professional intermediate
that can evaluate the
quality of that advice.
So what FDA has done,
just in the past year,
is they've said that
we're going to treat
these AI-based quote-unquote
devices as medical devices.
And we're going to apply the
same regulatory requirements
that we have for these
devices, except we don't really
know how to do this.
So there's a kind of
experiment going on right now
where they're saying, OK,
submit applications for review
of these devices to us.
We will review them.
And we will use these criteria--
product quality, patient
safety, clinical responsibility,
cybersecurity responsibility,
and a so-called proactive
culture in the organization
that's developing them--
in order to make a judgment
of whether or not to let you
proceed with marketing
one of these things.
So if you look, there are
in fact about 10 devices,
quote-unquote-- these
are all software--
that have been
approved so far by FDA.
And almost all of them
are imaging devices.
They're things that do
convolutional networks
over one thing or another.
And so here are
just a few examples.
Imagen has OsteoDetect, which
analyzes two-dimensional X-ray
images for signs of
distal radius fracture.
So if you break your
wrist, then this system
will look at the X-ray
and decide whether or not
you've done that.
Here's one from IDx, which
looks at the photographs
of your retina and
decides whether you
have diabetic retinopathy.
And actually, they've
published a lot
of papers that show that they
can also identify heart disease
and stroke risk and
various other things
from those same photographs.
So FDA has granted them
approval to market this thing.
Another one is Viz, which
automatically analyzes
CT scans for ER patients
and is looking for blockages
and major brain blood vessels.
So this can obviously
lead to a stroke.
And this is an automated
technique that does that.
Here's another one.
Arterys measures and tracks
tumors or potential cancers
in radiology images.
So these are the ones
that have been approved.
And then I just
wanted to remind you
that there's actually
plenty of literature
about this kind of stuff.
So the book on the left
actually comes out next week.
I got to read a pre-print
of it, by Eric Topol,
who's one of these
doctors who writes
a lot about the
future of medicine.
And he actually goes
through tons and tons
of examples of not
only the systems
that have been approved
by FDA, but also
things that are in
the works that he's
very optimistic that these
will again revolutionize
the practice of medicine.
Bob Wachter, who wrote the book
on the left a couple of years
ago, is a little
bit more cautious
because he's chief of
medicine at UC San Francisco.
And he wrote this
book in response
to them almost killing
a kid by giving him
a 39x overdose of a medication.
They didn't quite succeed
in killing the kid.
So it turned out OK.
But he was really
concerned about how
this wonderful technology led
to such a disastrous outcome.
And so he spent a
year studying how
these systems were being
used, and writes a more
cautionary tale.
So let me turn to
Adam, who as I said,
is a professor at the Brigham
and Harvard Medical School.
Please come and join me, and
we can have a conversation.
ADAM WRIGHT: So my
name is Adam Wright.
I'm an associate professor of
medicine at Harvard Medical
School.
In that role, I lead
a research program
and I teach the introduction to
biomedical informatics courses
at the medical school.
So if you're interested
in the topics
that Pete was
talking about today,
you should definitely
consider cross-registering
in VMI 701 or 702.
The medical school
certainly always
could use a few more
enthusiastic and
technically-minded machine
learning experts in our course.
And then I have a
operational job at Partners.
Partners is the
health system that
includes Mass General
Hospital and the Brigham
and some community hospitals.
And I work on
Partners eCare, which
is our kind of cool
brand name for Epic.
So Epic is the EHR that
we use at Partners.
And I help oversee the clinical
decision support there.
So we have a decision
support team.
I'm the clinical lead for
monitoring and evaluation.
And so I help make sure
that our decision support
systems of the type that Pete's
talking about work correctly.
So that's my job at the
Brigham and at Partners.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Cool.
And I appreciate it very much.
ADAM WRIGHT: Thanks.
I appreciate the invitation.
It's fun to be here.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So Adam,
the first obvious question
is what kind of
decision support systems
have you guys
actually put in place?
ADAM WRIGHT: Absolutely.
So we've had a long history
at the Brigham and Partners
of using decision support.
Historically, we developed our
own electronic health record,
which was a little bit unusual.
About three years
ago, we switched
from our self-developed
system to Epic,
which is a very widely-used
commercial electronic health
record.
And to the point that
you gave, we really
started with a lot of
medication-related decision
support.
So that's things like drug
interaction, alerting.
So you prescribe two drugs that
might interact with each other.
And we use a table--
no machine learning or anything
too complicated-- that says,
we think this drug might
interact with this.
We raise an alert to the
doctor, to the pharmacist.
And they make a decision,
using their expertise
as the learned
intermediary, that they're
going to continue with
that prescription.
Let's have some dosing
support, allergy checking,
and things like that.
So our first set
of decision support
really was around medications.
And then we turned to
a broader set of things
like preventative
care reminders,
so identifying patients that
are overdue for a mammogram
or a pap smear or that
might benefit from a statin
or something like that.
Or a beta blocker, in the case
of acute myocardial infarction.
And we make suggestions
to the doctor
or to other members of the
care team to do those things.
Again, those historically
have largely been rule-based.
So some experts sat down and
wrote Boolean if-then rules,
using variables that are
in a patient's chart.
We have increasingly,
though, started
trying to use some
predictive models for things
like readmission or whether a
patient is at risk of falling
down in the hospital.
A big problem that
patients often encounter
is they're in the hospital,
they're kind of delirious.
The hospital is a weird place.
It's dark.
They get up to go
to the bathroom.
They trip on their IV
tubing, and then they
fall and are injured.
So we would like to prevent
that from happening.
Because that's obviously
kind of a bad thing
to happen to you once
you're in the hospital.
So we have some machine
learning-based tools
for predicting patients
that are at risk for falls.
And then there is a
set of interventions
like putting the bed rails up
or putting an alarm that buzzes
when if they get out of bed.
Or in more extreme cases,
having a sitter, like a person
who actually sits in
the room with them
and tries to keep
them from getting up
or assists them to the bathroom.
Or calls someone who can
assist them to the bathroom.
So we have increasingly
started using
those machine learning tools.
Some of which we get
from third parties,
like from our electronic
health record vendor,
and some of which we
sort of train ourselves
on our own data.
That's a newer pursuit for
us, is this machine learning.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So
when you have something
like a risk model,
how do you decide
where to set the threshold?
You know, if I'm at
53% risk of falling,
should you get a sitter
to sit by my bedside?
ADAM WRIGHT: It's
complicated, right?
I mean, I would like
to say that what we do
is a full kind of
utility analysis,
where we say, we pay a
sitter this much per hour.
And the risk of
falling is this much.
And the cost of a fall--
most patients who
fall aren't hurt.
But some are.
And so you would
calculate the cost-benefit
of each of those
things and figure out
where on the ROC curve you
want to place yourself.
In practice, I think we
often just play it by ear,
in part because a
lot of our things
are intended to be suggestions.
So our threshold for
saying to the doctor,
hey, this patient is at
elevated risk for fall,
consider doing
something, is pretty low.
If the system were, say,
automatically ordering
a sitter, we might
set it higher.
I would say that's
an area of research.
I would also say that one
challenge we have is we
often set and forget
these kinds of systems.
And so there is kind of
feature drift and patients
change over time.
We probably should do a better
job of then looking back
to see how well they're
actually working
and making tweaks
to the thresholds.
Really good question.
PETER SZOLOVITS: But
these are, of course,
very complicated decisions.
I remember 50 years ago talking
to some people in the Air Force
about how much should they
invest in safety measures.
And they had a utility
theoretic model
that said, OK, how much
does it cost to replace
a pilot if you kill them?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yikes.
Yeah.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And this
was not publicized a lot.
ADAM WRIGHT: I mean,
we do calculate things
like quality-adjusted
life-years and
disability-adjusted life-years.
So there is-- in all of medicine
as people deploy resources,
this calculus.
And I think we tend to
assign a really high weight
to patient harm, because
patient harm is--
if you think about the
oath the doctors swear,
first do no harm.
The worst thing we can do
is harm you in the hospital.
So I think we have a pretty
strong aversion to do that.
But it's very hard to
weigh these things.
I think one of the
challenges we often run into
is that different doctors
would make different decisions.
So if you put the same
patient in front of 10 doctors
and said, does this
patient need a sitter?
Maybe half would say yes
and half would say no.
So it's especially
hard to know what
to do with a decision
support system
if the humans can't
agree on what you
should do in that situation.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So the
other thing we talked about
on the phone yesterday is I was
concerned-- a few years ago,
I was visiting one of these
august Boston-area hospitals
and asked to see an example of
somebody interacting with this
Computerized Physician
Order Entry system.
And the senior resident who
was taking me around went up
to the computer
and said, well, I
think I remember
how to use this.
And I said, wait a minute.
This is something you're
expected to use daily.
But in reality, what
happens is that it's not
the senior doctors or even
the medium senior doctors.
It's the interns and
the junior residents
who actually use the systems.
ADAM WRIGHT: This is true.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And
the concern I had
was that it takes a junior
resident with a lot of guts
to go up to the
chief of your service
and say, doctor x, even
though you asked me to order
this drug for this
patient, the computer
is arguing back that you should
use this other one instead.
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah, it does.
And in fact, I actually
thought of this a little more
after we chatted about it.
We've heard from
residents that people
have said to them,
if you dare page me
with an Epic suggestion in
the middle of the night,
I'll never talk to you again.
So just override
all of those alerts.
I think that one of
the challenges is--
and some culpability
on our part--
is that a lot of
these alerts we give
have a PPV of like, 10 or 20%.
They are usually wrong.
We think it's really
important, so we really
raise these alerts a lot.
But people experience this
kind of alert fatigue, or what
people call alarm fatigue.
You see this in cockpits, too.
But people get too
many alerts, and they
start ignoring the alerts.
They assume that they're wrong.
They tell the resident
not to page them
in the middle of the night, no
matter what the computer says.
So I do think that we have
some responsibility to improve
the accuracy of these alerts.
I do think machine
learning could help us.
We're actually just
having a meeting
about a pneumococcal
vaccination alert.
This is something that
helps people remember
to prescribe this vaccination
to help you not get pneumonia.
And it takes four or five
variables into account.
We started looking at
the cases where people
would override the alert.
And they were
mostly appropriate.
So the patient is in a really
extreme state right now.
Or conversely, the patient
is close to the end of life.
And they're not going to
benefit from this vaccination.
If the patient has
a phobia of needles,
if the patient has
an insurance problem.
And we think there's probably
more like 30 or 40 variables
that you would need to
take into account to make
that really accurate.
So the question is, when you
have that many variables,
can a human develop and
maintain that logic?
Or would we be better off
trying to use a machine learning
system to do that?
And would that
really work or not?
PETER SZOLOVITS:
So how far are we
from being able to use a machine
learning system to do that?
ADAM WRIGHT: I think that the
biggest challenge, honestly,
relates to the
availability and accuracy
of the data in our systems.
So Epic, which is the
EHR that we're using--
and Cerner and Allscripts and
most of the major systems--
have various ways to run
even sophisticated machine
learning models, either
inside of the system
or bolted onto the system and
then feeding model inferences
back into the system.
When I was giving that
example of the pneumococcal
vaccination, one of
the major problems
is that there's not always
a really good structured way
in the system that we
indicate that a patient is
at the end of life and
receiving comfort measures only.
Or that the patient is in
a really extreme state,
that we're in the
middle of a code blue
and that we need to
pause for a second
and stop giving these kind
of friendly preventive care
suggestions.
So I would actually say
that the biggest barrier
to really good
machine-learning-based decision
support is just the lack of
good, reliably documented,
coded usable features.
I think that the second
challenge, obviously,
is workflow.
You said-- it's sometimes hard
to know in the hospital who
a patient's doctor is.
The patient is admitted.
And on the care team is an
intern, a junior resident,
and a fellow, an attending,
several specialists,
a couple of nurses.
Who should get that message
or who should get that page?
I think workflow is second.
This is where I think
you may have said,
I have some optimism.
I actually think that the
technical ability of our EHR
software to run these
models is better
than it was three
or five years ago.
And it's, actually, usually
not the barrier in the studies
that we've done.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So
there were attempts--
again, 20 years ago--
to create formal
rules about who gets
notified under
what circumstances.
I remember one of the doctors
I worked with at Tufts Medical
Center was going crazy, because
when they implemented a new lab
information system, it would
alert on every abnormal lab.
And this was crazy.
But there were other
hospitals that said, well,
let's be a little more
sophisticated about when
it's necessary to alert.
And then if somebody
doesn't respond to an alert
within a very short
period of time,
then we escalate it to somebody
higher up or somebody else
on the care team.
And that seemed like a
reasonable idea to me.
But are there things
like that in place now?
ADAM WRIGHT: There are.
It works very differently in
the inpatient and the outpatient
setting.
At the inpatient setting,
we're writing very acute care
to a patient.
And so we have processes
where people sign in and out
of the care team.
In fact, these prevalence
of these automated messages
is an incentive to do that well.
If I go home, I better sign
myself out of that patient,
otherwise I'm going to get
all these pages all night
about them.
And the system will
always make sure
that somebody is the
responding provider.
It becomes a little thornier
in the outpatient setting,
because a lot of the academic
doctors at the Brigham
only have clinic
half a day a week.
And so the question is, if an
abnormal result comes back,
should I send it to that doctor?
Should I send it to the person
that's on call in that clinic?
Should I send it to
the head of the clinic?
There are also these edge
cases that mess us up a lot.
So a classic one is a
patient is in the hospital.
I've ordered some lab tests.
They're looking well, so
I discharge the patient.
The test is still pending at the
time the patient is discharged.
And now, who does that go to?
Should it go to the patient's
primary care doctor?
Do they have a
Should it go to the person
that ordered the test?
That person may be
on vacation now,
if it's a test that takes
a few weeks to come back.
So we still struggle with--
we call those TPADs--
tests pending at discharge.
We still struggle with
some of those edge cases.
But I think in the core,
we're pretty good at it.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So one of
the things we talked about
is an experience I've had and
you've probably had that--
for example, a few
years ago I was
working with the people who
run the clinical labs at Mass
General.
And they run some ancient
laboratory information systems
that, as you said, can add
and subtract but not multiply
or divide.
ADAM WRIGHT: They can add and
multiply, but not subtract
or divide.
Yes.
And it doesn't support
negative numbers.
Only unsigned integers.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So there are
these wonderful legacy systems
around that really create
horrendous problems,
because if you try
to build anything--
I mean, even a risk
prediction calculator--
it really helps to be able to
divide as well as multiply.
So we've struggled
in that project.
And I'm sure you've had similar
experiences with how do we
incorporate a decision
support system into some
of this squeaky old technology
that just doesn't support it?
So what's the right
approach to that?
ADAM WRIGHT: There are
a lot of architectures
and they all have pros and cons.
I'm not sure if any one of
them is the right approach.
I think we often do favor using
these creaky old technology
or the new technology.
So Epic has a built
in rule engine.
That laboratory you talked about
has a basic calculation engine
with some significant
limitations to it.
So where we can,
we often will try
to build rules internally
using these systems.
Those tend to have real-time
availability of data, the best
ability to sort of push
alerts to the person
right in their workflow and make
though those alerts actionable.
In cases where we can't do
that-- like for example,
a model that's too complex
to execute in the system--
one thing that we've often
done is run that model
against our data warehouse.
So we have a data
warehouse that extracts
the data from the
electronic health record
every night at midnight.
So if we don't need real-time
data, it's possible to run--
extract the data, run a
model, and then actually write
a risk score or a flag back
into the patient's record
that can then be shown
to the clinician,
or used to drive an alert
or something like that.
That works really well, except
that a lot of things that
happen-- particularly
in an inpatient setting,
like predicting sepsis--
depend on real-time data.
Data that we need right away.
And so we run into the challenge
where that particular approach
only works on a 24-hour
kind of retrospective basis.
We have also developed systems
that depend on messages.
So there's this-- HL7
is a standard format
for exchanging data with an
electronic health record.
There's various versions
and profiles of HL7.
But you can set up
an infrastructure
that sits outside of the EHR
and gets messages in real time
from the EHR.
It makes inferences and sends
messages back into the EHR.
Increasingly, EHRs
also do support kind
of web service approaches.
So that you can
register a hook and say,
call my hook whenever
this thing happens.
Or you can pull the EHR to get
data out and use another web
service to write data back in.
That's worked
really well for us.
You can also ask the EHR to
embed an app that you develop.
So people here may
have heard-- or should
hear at some point--
about SMART on FHIR,
which is a open kind of API
that allows you to develop
an application and
embed that application
into an electronic
health record.
We've increasingly been building
some of those applications.
The downside right
now of the smart apps
is that they're really
good for reading data out
of the record and sort of
visualizing or displaying it.
But they don't always
have a lot of capability
to write data back into
the record or take actions.
Most of the EHR vendors also
have a proprietary approach,
like an app store.
So Epic calls theirs
the App Orchard.
And most of the EHRs
have something similar,
where you can join
a developer program
and build an application.
And those are often
more full-featured.
They tend to be proprietary.
So if you build
one Epic app, you
have to then build a Cerner
app and an Allscripts app
and an eClinicalWorks
app separately.
There are often heavy fees
for joining those programs,
although the EHR vendors--
Epic in particular-- have
lowered their prices a lot.
The federal
government, the Office
of the National
Coordinator of Health IT,
just about a week and a half ago
released some new regulations
which really limit the rate
at which vendors can charge
application developers
for API access
basically to almost
nothing, except for
incremental computation
costs or special support.
So I think that may
change everything now
that that regulation's
been promulgated.
So we'll see.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So contrary
to my pessimistic beginning,
this actually is the thing
that makes me most optimistic.
That even five years
ago, if you looked
at many of these systems, they
essentially locked you out.
I remember in the
early 2000s, I was
at the University
of Pittsburgh, where
they had one of the
first centers that was
doing heart-lung transplants.
So their people had built
a special application
for supporting heart-lung
transplant patients,
in their own homemade electronic
medical records system.
And then UPMC went to
Cerner at the time.
And I remember I
was at some meeting
where the doctors who ran this
heart-lung transplant unit
were talking to the
Cerner people and saying,
how could we get something
to support our special needs
for our patients?
And Cerner's answer was,
well, commercially it doesn't
make sense for us to do this.
Because at the time there
were like four hospitals
in the country that did this.
And so it's not a
big money maker.
So their offer was, well, you
pay us an extra $3 million
and within three
years we will develop
the appropriate
software for you.
So that's just crazy, right?
I mean, that's a
totally untenable way
of going about things.
And now that there are
systematic ways for you
either to embed your own code
into one of these systems,
or at least to have a
well-documented, reasonable way
of feeding data out and
then feeding results back
into the system, that
makes it possible to do
special-purpose
applications like this.
Or experimental applications
or all kinds of novel things.
So that's great.
ADAM WRIGHT: That's what
we're optimistic about.
And I think it's worth adding
that there's two barriers you
have to get through right.
One is Epic has
to sort of let you
into their App Orchard,
which is the barrier that
is increasingly lower.
And then you need to find
a hospital or a health care
provider that wants to
use your app, right.
So you have to
clear both of those,
but I think it's
increasingly possible.
You've got smart
people here at MIT,
or at the hospitals that we
have in Boston always wanting
to build these apps.
And I would say five years ago
we would've told people, sorry,
it's not possible.
And today we're able,
usually, to tell people
that if there's
clinical interest,
the technical part
will fall into place.
So that's exciting for us.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah
AUDIENCE: Question about that.
ADAM WRIGHT: Absolutely
AUDIENCE: Some of the
applications that you
guys develop in
house, do you also
put those on the Epic
Orchard, or do you
just sort of implement it one
time within your own system?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah, there's
a lot of different ways
that we share these
applications, right.
So a lot of us are researchers.
So we will release
an open source
version of the application
or write a paper and say,
this is available.
And we'll share it with you.
The App Orchard is particularly
focused on applications
that you want to sell.
So our hospital hasn't
decided that we wanted
to sell any applications.
We've given a lot of
applications away.
Epic also has something called
the Community Library, which
is like the AppOrchard, but it's
free instead of costing money.
And so we released
a ton of stuff
through the Community Library.
To the point that I
was poking out before,
one of the challenges is that
if we build a Smart on FHIR app,
we're able to sort of
share that publicly.
And we can post that on the
web or put it on GitHub.
And anybody can use it.
Epic has a position that
their APIs are proprietary.
And they represent Epic's
valuable intellectual property
or trade secrets.
And so we're only allowed
to share those apps
through the Epic ecosystem.
And so, we often now,
when we get a grant--
most of my work is
through grants--
we'll have an Epic site.
And we'll share that through
the Community Library.
And we'll have a Cerner site.
And we'll share it through
Cerner's equivalent.
But I think until the
capability of the open APIs,
like Smart on FHIR,
reaches the same level
as the proprietary APIs,
we're still somewhat locked
into having to build
different versions
and distribute three-- each
EHR under separate channels.
Really, really good question.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And
so what's lacking
in things like Smart on FHIR--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
PETER SZOLOVITS: --that you
get from the native interfaces?
ADAM WRIGHT: So it's
very situational, right.
So, for example, in some
EHR implementations,
the Smart on FHIR will give
you a list of the patient's
current medications
but may not give you
historical medications.
Or it will tell you that
the medicine is ordered,
but it won't tell you whether
it's been administered.
So one half of the battle
is less complete data.
The other one is that
most EHRs are not
implementing, at
this point, the sort
of write back capabilities, or
the actionable capabilities,
that Smart on FHIR is
sort of working on.
And it's really some
standards for us.
So if we want to build
an application that
shows how a patient fits on
a growth curve, that's fine.
If we went to build
an application that
suggests ordering medicines,
that can be really challenging.
Whereas the internal APIs that
the vendors provide typically
have both read and
write capabilities.
So that's the other challenge.
PETER SZOLOVITS:
And do the vendors
worry about, I guess
two related things,
one is sort of
cognitive overload.
Because if you build
1,000 Smart on FHIR apps,
and they all start firing
for these inpatients,
you're going to be back
in the same situation
of over-alerting.
And the other question is, are
they worried about liability?
Since if you were
using their system
to display recommendations, and
those recommendations turn out
to be wrong and
harm some patient,
then somebody will
reach out to them
legally because they
have a lot of money.
ADAM WRIGHT: Absolutely.
They're worried
about both of those.
Related particularly
to the second one,
they're also worried about just
sort of corruption or integrity
of the data, right.
So somehow if I can write
a medication order directly
to the database, and it
may bypass certain checks
that would be done normally.
And I could potentially enter
a wrong or dangerous order.
The other thing that
we're increasingly hearing
is concerns about protection
of data, sort of Cambridge
Analytica style worries, right.
So if I, as an Epic
patient, authorize the Words
With Friends app to
see my medical record,
and then they post
that on the web,
or monetize it in some
sort of a tricky way,
what liability, if any,
does my health care
provider organization, or my--
the EHR vendor, have for that?
And the new regulations are
extremely strict, right.
They say that if a patient asks
you to, and authorizes an app
to access their record, you
may not block that access,
even if you consider that
app to be a bad actor.
So that's I think an area
of liability that is just
beginning to be sorted out.
And it is, I think,
some cause for concern.
But at the same time, you
could imagine a universe
where, I think, there
are conservative health
organizations that would
choose to never authorize
any application to avoid risk.
So how you balance
that is not yet solved.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Well--
and to avoid leakage.
ADAM WRIGHT: Absolutely.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So I
remember years ago there
was a lot of reluctance, even
among Boston area hospitals,
to share data, because
they were worried
that another
hospital could cherry
pick their most lucrative
patients by figuring out
something about them.
So I'm sure that that hasn't
gone away as a concern.
ADAM WRIGHT: Absolutely, yeah.
PETER SZOLOVITS: OK, we're going
to try to remember to repeat
the questions you're asking--
ADAM WRIGHT: Oh great, OK.
PETER SZOLOVITS: --because
of the recording.
ADAM WRIGHT: Happy to.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how does
a third party vendor
deploy a machine learning
model on your system?
So is that done through Epic?
Obviously, there's the
App Orchard kind of thing,
but is there ways to go
around that and go directly
into partners and whatnot?
And how does that work?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
So the question is how
does a third party vendor
deploy an application
or a machine
learning model or
something like that?
And so with Epic, there's
always a relationship
between the vendor of the
application and the health care
provider organization.
And so we could work
together directly.
So if you had an app that
the Brigham wanted to use,
you could share that app
with us in a number of ways.
So Epic supports this thing
called Predictive Modeling
Markup Language, or PMML.
So if you train a model,
you can export a PMML model.
And I can import it into
Epic and run it natively.
Or you can produce a web service
that I call out to and gives me
an answer.
We could work together directly.
However, there are
some limitations
in what I'm allowed to tell you
or share with you about Epic's
data model and what
Epic perceives to be
their intellectual property.
And it is facilitated by
you joining this program.
Because if you
join this program,
you get access to documentation
that you would otherwise not
have access to.
You may get access to a test
harness or a test system that
lets you sort of
validate your work.
However, people who
join the program often
think that means
that I can then just
run my app at every
customer, right.
But with Epic, in
particular, you
have to then make a deal with
me to use it at the Brigham
and make a deal with my
colleague to use at Stanford.
Other EHR vendors have
developed a more sort
of centralized model
where you can actually
release it and
sell it, and I can
pay for it directly through
the app store and integrate it.
I think that last mile
piece hasn't really
been standardized yet.
AUDIENCE: I guess
one of my questions
there is, what
happens in the case
that I don't want to
talk to Epic at all?
And just I looked at
your data and just
like Brigham and Women's stuff.
And I build a really good model.
You saw how it works, and
we just want to deploy it.
ADAM WRIGHT: Epic would not
stop us from doing that.
The only real
restriction is that Epic
would limit my ability to tell
you stuff about Epic's guts.
And so you would need a
relatively sophisticated health
care provider
organization who could
map between some kind of
platonic data, clinical data,
model and Epic's
internal data model.
But if you had that, you could.
And at the Brigham, we have
this iHub Innovation Program.
And we're probably working
with 50 to 100 startups
doing work like
that, some of whom
are members of the
Epic App Orchard
and some who choose not to
be members of the Epic App
Orchard.
It's worth saying
that joining the App
Orchard or these programs
entails revenue sharing
with Epic and some complexity.
That may go way down with
these new regulations.
But right now,
some organizations
have chosen not to
partner with the vendors
and work directly
with the health care
provider organizations.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So on the
quality side of that question,
if you do develop an application
and field it at the Brigham,
will Stanford be
interested in taking it?
Or are they going to be
concerned about the fact
that somehow you've fit it
to the patient population
in Boston, and it won't be
appropriate to their data?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah, I think
that's a fundamental question,
right, is to what extent do
these models generalize, right?
Can you train a
model at one place
and transfer it
to another place?
We've generally seen
that many of them
transfer pretty well, right.
So if they really
have more to do
with kind of core
human physiology,
that can be pretty similar
between organizations.
If they're really bound up
in a particular workflow,
right, they assume that you're
doing this task, this task,
this task in this order, they
tend to transfer really, really
poorly.
So I would say that our
general approach has
been to take a model
that somebody has,
run it retrospectively
on our data warehouse,
and see if it's accurate.
And if it is, we might
go forward with it.
If it's not, we would try
to retrain it on our data,
and then see how
much improvement we
get by retraining it.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And
so have you in fact
imported such models
from other places?
ADAM WRIGHT: We have, yeah.
Epic provides five
or six models.
And we've just started using
some of them at the Brigham
or just kind of signed the
license to begin using them.
And I think Epic's
guidance and our experience
is that they work pretty
well out of the box.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Great.
AUDIENCE: So could you
say a little bit more
about these rescores
that are being deployed,
maybe they work.
Maybe they don't.
How can you really tell
whether they're working, even
just beyond patient
shift over time,
just like how people
react to the scores.
Like I know a lot of the
bias in fairness works
is like people, if a score
agrees with their intuition,
they'll trust it.
And if it doesn't,
they ignore the score.
So like how-- what
does the process look
like before you
deploy the score thing
and then see whether
it's working or not?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah, absolutely.
So the question is,
we get a risk score,
or we deploy a new
risk score that says,
patient has a risk of
falling, or patient
has a risk of having sepsis
or something like that.
We tend to do several
levels of evaluation, right.
So the first level is, when
we show the score, what
do people do, right?
If we-- typically we
don't just show a score,
we make a recommendation.
We say, based on
the score we think
you should order a lactate
to see if the patient is
at risk of having sepsis.
First we look to see if
people do what we say, right.
So we think it's a good sign if
people follow the suggestions.
But ultimately,
we view ourselves
as sort of clinical
trialists, right.
So we deploy this model with
an intent to move something,
to reduce the rate of sepsis, or
to reduce the rate of mortality
in sepsis.
And so we would try to sort
of measure, if nothing else,
do a before and
after study, right,
measure the rates before,
implement this intervention,
and measure the rates after.
In cases where we're less
sure, or where we really
care about the
results, we'll even
do a randomized trial, right.
So we'll give half of the
units will get the alert,
half the units
won't get the alert.
And we'll compare the
effect on a clinical outcome
and see what the difference is.
In our opinion, unless
we can show an effect
on these clinical
measures, we shouldn't
be bothering people, right.
Pete made this point
that what's the purpose
of having-- if we
have 1,000 alerts,
everyone will be overwhelmed.
So we should only
keep alerts on if we
can show that they're making
a real clinical difference.
AUDIENCE: And are those sort
of like just internal checks,
are there papers of some
of these deployments?
ADAM WRIGHT: It's our--
it's our intent to
publish everything, right.
I mean, I think we're behind.
But I'd say, we
publish everything.
We have some things
that we've finished
that we haven't published yet.
They're sort of the next
thing to sort of come out.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess so
earlier we were talking
about how the models are just
used to give recommendations
to doctors.
Do you have any metric, in
terms of how often the model
recommendation matches
with the doctor's decision?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
ADAM WRIGHT: Oh yeah.
Thanks, David.
So the question is,
do we ever check
to see how often the model
recommendation matches
what the doctor does?
And so there's sort of
two ways we do that.
We'll often retrospectively
test the model back.
I think Pete shared
a paper from Cerner
where they looked at
these sort of suggestions
that they made to
order lactates or to do
other sort of sepsis work.
And they looked to see whether
the recommendations that they
made matched what the
doctors had actually done.
And they showed that
they, in many cases, did.
So that'll be the first
thing that we do is,
before we even turn the model
on, we'll run it in silent mode
and see if the doctor
does what we suggest.
Now the doctor is not a
perfect supervision, right,
because the doctor may
neglect to do something
that would be good to do.
So then when we turn
it on, we actually
look to see whether
the doctor takes
the action that we suggested.
And if we're doing it
in this randomized mode,
we would then look to see
whether the doctor takes
the action we suggested more
often in the case where we show
the alert, than where we
generate the alert but just
logged it and don't--
don't show it.
Yeah.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So you'd
mentioned how there's
kind of related to fatigue--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --if it's a code
blue, these alarms will--
ADAM WRIGHT: Right.
AUDIENCE: And you said
that cockpits have--
pilots now--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --that have
similar problems.
My very limited
understanding of aviation
is that if you're flying,
say, below 10,000 feet,
then almost all of the--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --alarms
get turned off, and--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --I don't know if
there seems to be an airlock
for that, for--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --hospitals yet.
And is that just because
the technology workflow
is not mature enough
yet, only 10 years old?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or is that kind
of the team's question
about the incentives between
if you build the tool
and it doesn't flag this thing--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --the patient
dies, then they could sued.
And so they're just very--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah,
no, we try, right?
So since we often don't
know about the situations
in a structured way at the EHR.
And so most of our alerts are
suppressed in the operating
room, right?
So during an-- when a
patient is on anesthesia,
their physiology is
being sort of manually
controlled by a doctor.
And so we often suppress the
alerts in those situations.
I guess I didn't say the
question, but the question was,
do we try to take
situations into account
or how much can we?
We didn't used to know that
a code blue was going on,
because we used to do most of
our code blue documentation
on paper.
We now use this code
narrator, right?
So we can tell when
a code blue starts
and when a code blue ends.
A code blue is a cardiac arrest
and resuscitation of a patient.
And so we actually
do increasingly
turn a lot of alerting
off during a code blue.
I get an email or
a page whenever
a doctor overrides an alert
and writes a cranky message.
And they'll often say something
like, this patient is dying
of a myocardial
infarction right now,
and your bothering me about
this influenza vaccination.
And then what I'll
do is I'll go back--
no, seriously, I
had that yesterday.
And so what I'll do is I'll
go back and look in the record
and say, what signs did
I have this patient sort
of in extremis?
And in that particular
case, it was
a patient who came into the ED
and very little documentation
had been started,
and so there actually
were very few signs that the
patient was in the acute state.
I think this, someday,
could be sorted
by integrating monitor data and
device data to figure that out.
But at that point, we didn't
have a good, structured data
at that moment,
in the chart, that
said this patient
is so ill that it's
offensive to suggest an
influenza vaccination right
now.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Now,
there are hospitals
that have started experimenting
with things like acquiring data
from the ambulance as
the patient is coming in
so that the ED is already
primed with preliminary data.
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And in that
circumstance, you could tell.
ADAM WRIGHT: So this is the
interoperability challenge,
right?
So we actually get
the run sheet, all
of the ambulance data, to us.
It comes in as a PDF that's
transmitted from the ambulance
emergency management
system to our EHR.
And so it's not coming in in a
way that we can read it well.
But to your point,
exactly, if we were better
at interoperability--
I've also talked to
hospitals who use things
like video cameras
and people's badges,
and if there's 50 people
hovering around a patient,
that's a sign that
something bad is happening.
And so we might be able to
use something like that.
But yeah, we'd like
to be better at that.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So why
did HL7 version 3 not solve
all of these problems?
ADAM WRIGHT: This is a good
philosophical question.
Come to BMI 701 and 702 and
we'll talk about the standards.
HL7 version-- to his
question-- version 2
was a very practical standard.
Version 3 was a very deeply
philosophical standard--
PETER SZOLOVITS: Aspirational.
ADAM WRIGHT: --aspirational,
that never quite caught on.
And it did in pieces.
I mean, FHIR is a
simplification of that.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
ADAM WRIGHT: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So I think usually,
the machine learning models
evaluates the
difficult [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM WRIGHT: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: When it comes
to a particular patient,
is there a way to know
how reliable the model is?
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah, I mean,
there's calibration, right?
So we can say this
model works particularly
well in these patients, or
not as well in these patients.
There are some very
simple equations
or models that we use,
for example, where
we use a different model in
African-American patients
versus non-African-American
patients,
because there's some data
that says this model is better
calibrated in this subgroup
of patients versus another.
I do think, though,
to your point,
that there's a
suggestion, an inference
from a model-- this patient
is at risk of a fall.
And then there's this whole set
of value judgments and beliefs
and knowledge and understanding
of a patient's circumstances
that are very human.
And I think that
that's largely why
we deliver these suggestions
to a doctor or to a nurse.
And then that human
uses that information
plus their expertise
and their relationship
and their experience to make
a suggestion, rather than just
having the computer adjust the
knob on the ventilator itself.
A question that
people always ask me,
and that you should ask
me, is, will we eventually
not need that human?
And I think I'm more
optimistic than some people
that there are cases where
the computer is good enough,
or the human is
poor enough, that it
would be safe to have
a close to closed loop.
However, I think those
cases are not the norm.
I think that there'll be more
cases where human doctors are
still very much needed.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So
just to add that there
are tasks where patients
are fungible, in the words
that I used a few lectures ago.
So for example, a
lot of hospitals
are developing models that
predict whether a patient will
show up for their optional
surgery, because then they
can do a better job of
over-scheduling the operating
room in the same way that the
airlines over over-sell seats.
Because, statistically,
you could win doing that.
Those are very safe predictions,
because the worst thing that
happens is you get delayed.
But it's not going to
have a harmful outcome
on an individual patient.
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah,
and conversely, there
are people that are working
on machine learning systems
for dosing insulin or adjusting
people's ventilator settings,
and those are high--
PETER SZOLOVITS: Those
are the high risk.
ADAM WRIGHT: --risk jobs.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yep.
All right, last question
because we have to wrap up.
AUDIENCE: You had alluded
to some of the [INAUDIBLE]
problems--
ADAM WRIGHT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --of some
of these models.
I'm, one, curious
how long [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM WRIGHT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I
guess, two, once it's
been determined that actually a
significant issue has occurred,
what are some of the decisions
that you made regarding
tradeoffs of using the
out-of-date model that
looks at [INAUDIBLE] signal
versus the cost of retraining?
ADAM WRIGHT: Retraining?
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
So the question is the
set-and-forget, right?
We build the model.
The model may become stale.
Should we update the model?
And how do we decide to do that?
I mean, we're using--
it depends on what
you define as a model.
We're using tables
and rules that we've
developed since the 1970s.
I think we have a
pretty high desire
to empirically revisit those.
There's a problem
in the practice
called knowledge management or
knowledge engineering, right?
How do we remember which
of our knowledge bases
need to be checked
again or updated?
And we'll often, just as a
standard, retrain a model
or re-evaluate a knowledge base
every six months or every year
because it's both
harmful to patients
if this stuff is
out-of-date, and it also
makes us look stupid, right?
So if there's a new paper
that comes out and says,
beta blockers are
terrible poison,
and we keep suggesting
them, then people no longer
believe the suggestions
that we make, that said,
we still make mistakes, right?
I mean, things happen
all of the time.
A lot of my work has focused on
malfunctions in these systems.
And so, as an example,
empirically, the pharmacy
might change the code or
ID number for a medicine,
or a new medicine might
come on the market,
and we have to make sure
to continually update
the knowledge base so that we're
not suggesting an old medicine
or overlooking the fact
that the patient has already
been prescribed a new medicine.
And so we tried to do that
prospectively or proactively.
But then we also tried to
listen to feedback from users
and fix things as we go.
Cool.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And just
one more comment on that.
So some things are
done in real time.
There was a system,
many years ago,
at the Intermountain Health
in Salt Lake City, where
they were looking at what
bugs were growing out
of microbiology samples
in the laboratory.
And of course, that can
change on an hour-by-hour or
day-to-day basis.
And so they were updating
those systems that warned you
about the possibility of that
kind of infection in real time
by taking feeds directly
from the laboratory.
ADAM WRIGHT: That's true.
PETER SZOLOVITS: All
right, thank you very much.
ADAM WRIGHT: No,
thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]